how to avoid getting screwed on odesk so
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys blitz
gamer triple zero who wrote in to say
i'm new in odesk and i don't know the
payment process and also how i know the
employer will pay me or not by the way
nice video so when i talk about odesk
i've done some videos from the employer
side of it and the employee side of it
and so
when you're a contractor you're the
employee going in here's what you really
want to look for okay there is a process
that the
employers go through to verify their
payment methods so
with each contract that you look at you
can look at who the employer is and
they'll have a little uh dollar sign in
their profile that'll say payment method
verify okay you want to look for that if
it's grayed out it'll say payment method
not verified that means that the
employer they haven't verified their
payment method so they still might be a
good potential employer but it's a it's
a bigger risk for you because they
haven't verified that they can actually
pay
so
you want to you want to watch out so i
would look for the payment method
verified and there's multiple payment
methods they can go through and so if
you look at that little green dollar
sign
some people have a full if fully filled
in green and some people will have it
somewhere along the way so it's like
three quarters green and one quarter
gray that means that they haven't
completed all the different methods so
for my account it's uh full green this
should be
check that out
uh but it means that i've verified my
paypal account it's also verified my
credit card and what it does is when i
verify my credit card as an employer
it actually bills me a certain amount i
think it's a dollar or less than a
dollar
and
that shows that my credit card actually
works like i put in a valid credit card
they're actually putting money on to it
and so they'll start to
as the as i hire you and we work
together they'll they'll take money out
of my credit card and if that doesn't
work to take money out of my paypal so
there's there's backup options
um to go with there so definitely by
looking at the payment method verified
looking for that green dollar sign
you're much less likely to get screwed
the other thing that happens is so
odesk will take the money out of
employers account
and put it into
uh to take 10 commission and then
they'll put it into your account and
there is a method to dispute i mean that
happens automatically right you'll
you'll either um
if you're doing it by the hour you'll
charge your hourly rate and they'll
they'll take it out once a week or if
you have a fixed fee
uh if something goes wrong if if the
employer doesn't like what is happening
if they don't want to pay you there's a
dispute method
where
you can both submit your argument to
odac's get odesk will review it and
make a claim make a judgment to see you
know who is right who's wrong but your
best bet really is to find
reputable people so on top of looking
for the payment method verified you can
look at the stars right so just like
ebay ranks its
vendors
you can look at past work right if
nobody if they haven't done any work on
odesk before
then it's riskier for you to take on
right but if they if they've hired lots
of people before and have over 10 000
hours and
have all five star reviews
then it's probably a safe bet
and then for the employer side you know
this is important because you take all
of this and put it in reverse where
you want to verify your payment methods
right you want to show that you've
included your paypal and your visa not
just one because that's a screening tool
if you want to get the best candidates
you want to make sure that you have your
payment methods all verified you want to
work hard like i work hard to get all of
my reviews five stars everybody who's
ever worked for me has left me a
five-star review
last time i checked
and so that helped separate me from
other employers who
when i put up my next job i'm going to
get better candidates because i've
verified my payments and i have great
reviews
so that is how to avoid getting screwed
on odettes for those of you watching you
like the video you can subscribe to my
channel you can support me by clicking
on the link in the description
and uh if you have questions or comments
leave it in the comment section below i
love helping
people do well in odessa it's been a
great resource for me i've met a lot of
great people who continue to be on my
team
and i'm happy to answer any questions
that come up if i can share from my
experience
so thank you guys believe and i'll see
you soon
you